some of California's most influential
women are speaking out against what they
call pervasive sexual harassment in the
political world 147 women including
lawmakers and lobbyists signed a public
letter detailing inappropriate behavior
in part it says enough the letter
follows allegations of sexual harassment
and abuse from dozens of women against
disgraced Hollywood movie mogul Harvey
Weinstein bianna golodryga is here with
how the women in politics found their
voice beyond a good morning good morning
that one word just sums it up and not
enough is enough and California is home
to some of the country's most powerful
women in politics including its first
female House Speaker Nancy Pelosi but
according to some women working at the
State Capitol hidden beneath the veneer
of the state's progressive image in
Sacramento lies an ugly epidemic of
sexual harassment it's very widespread
for for many women who work in politics
as a lobbyist in Sacramento pamela lopez
says she's been a victim of sexual
harassment the most disturbing incident
happened about two years ago he rushed
up behind me rushed me into the restroom
locked the door behind him exposed
himself began to masturbate all in a
matter of seconds
Lopez along with more than 140 other
women issued a letter blasting what they
call dehumanizing behavior men have
groped and touched us without our
consent
made inappropriate comments about our
bodies and our abilities insults and
sexual innuendo frequently disguised as
jokes have undermined our professional
positions and capabilities you touching
my body in a way that is not welcomed is
harassment
Democratic state Assemblywoman Christina
Garcia says a lobbyist grabbed her
inappropriately five years ago and
that's one of the reasons she signed the
letter Garcia says the issue of sexual
harassment is not only nonpartisan it
shouldn't even be a women's issue it's
not our responsibility it's not the
victims responsibility it's how do those
with power how did they help fix this
problem
the fallout over the Harvey Weinstein
scandal has prompted lawmakers around
the country to tell their stories from a
former South Dakota State Senator
sharing her experience on
Facebook to a Rhode Island state
representative who told the Providence
Journal I have been told sexual favors
would allow my bills to go further
adding it was someone who had a higher
ranking position authorities are now
reviewing her allegations everybody
needs to take this seriously as
something that is still way too common
at work and requires bold action to
solve we asked some of California's top
lawmakers about the letter and they all
condemned sexual harassment the woman
behind the letter are now turning it
into a public campaign creating a
website where other women can share
their stories and you know they said
that they'd been mentoring each other
privately for years this is the first
time though that they've come out
publicly and said you know we're not
just gonna respond to this behavior and
and then give women tips as to how to
respond to it we want to put this to an
end
good that this conversation is happening
I guess very good so pervasive you know
thank you very much